Mortal Kombat vs. DC surprisingly not
brought to you by nerf play safe
so Ed Boon in the Mortal Kombat crew
wanted to do something a little
differently with Mortal Kombat so DC
said yeah okay we'll do a crossover with
our guys versus your guys and there is
some good and bad to that so in the
recent 3d Mortal Kombat games like
Mortal Kombat Deadly Alliance deception
and Armageddon the games relied heavily
on this really clunky combo system I
mean yeah each guy had his own set of
special moves like fireballs and
teleports but it didn't matter because
the combos won the match you had to
memorize these sets of like seven to
twelve button combinations that you
couldn't build off of they didn't vary
they were set combos with no room for
improv and they made for a very clunky
experience in short I'm a huge Mortal
Kombat fan and that gameplay was crap
but with a new Mortal Kombat coming out
in April 2011 they promised to do away
with that combo system and revert back
to the classic Mortal Kombat game play
consisting and making your own combos
and juggles with your special moves and
imagination building your own combos is
pretty much the pinnacle of a fun
fighting game and I for one was
pleasantly surprised to see that they
already actually took a step in that
direction with Mortal Kombat vs. DC
Universe John is the clunky ass combo
system of the last three Mortal Kombat's
Mortal Kombat vs. DC Universe has taken
a step towards a more classic feel of
the old Mortal Kombat's rabid the
fighting system isn't exactly a deep one
but it's a hundred times better than the
last three what I don't like about this
fighting mechanic are two modes one
called freefall combat where you're
pretty much falling off a building and
you're beating the piss out of your
opponent but if they push the same
button you push they will flip you
around and you take all the damage which
the computer will always do to you and
another mode called close combat where
the camera zooms in you're pushing
buttons to beat up your opponent but if
your opponent pushes the same button you
push they break out of it which the
computer will always do to you these two
modes are pretty much based on luck and
I don't like luck determining a fighting
game so no to these modes and I have
void them when I can and the elephant in
the room the nerf bat fatalities so in
this crossover DC said yeah your guys
can fight our guys as long as your guys
don't rip our guy's heads off which a
little word of advice DC if you're going
to do a crossover and you don't want
Superman to get his head ripped off you
might not want to do a crossover with
Mortal Kombat just saying some of the
fatalities are actually pretty good at
being a teen rated game I mean
Deathstroke has a good one sub zero's
and some of them are absolute crap I
mean I understand that Superman can't
kill people and remain Superman so he
had to do something different with
people like him but for the people who
are killers like the Kaos yeah I said
knose like it was plural they should be
able to rip out his fine
just saying I mean fatalities and blood
don't determine a better game the Super
Nintendo mortal kombat was superior to
the Sega Genesis Mortal Kombat in terms
of graphics sound and gameplay even
though Genesis had blood and Super
Nintendo didn't but some of the
fatalities and MK vs. DC could have been
a little more you know fatal like what's
up with Kano a killer a criminal rolling
back and jumping on their stomach like
they're a Wii Fit or something that's
not fatal they can survive a 10-story
fall or even Superman pounding them into
the ground
but the moment Kano jumps on their
stomach that's curtains now that is
[ __ ] so in the end the teen rating
is a bit annoying and some of the
fatalities could have been better even
with a teen rating but the gameplay is a
hundred times better than the past three
mortal kombat and it's a great step in
the right direction in terms of gameplay
which if what we see is what we get
should be perfected with the new MK
coming out this April I mean yeah I
would have felt cheated if I bought this
game for 60 bucks but now that you can
buy 420 yeah it's definitely worth
buying for twenty bucks
especially if you need to hold over fix
between now and April Arnold on that and
that fellow mortal combatants is that in
terms of Mortal Kombat vs. DC and if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more than click right here to see
more